ah this is gonna sound very late night
II but I am truly a fan of your book of
poetry I am actually have one good app
egghead I love it it's it's so funny I
was wondering if you could read I marked
a couple of my favorite oh yeah
I don't know well hey just a little a
little force or something
did you market every house come here
smear you can swear a lot
it's the poem about beauty about
transformation about self-image for
women
Martha was ugly hey like a shaven baboon
so she wrapped herself up in a curtain
cocoon and after a week she finally
emerged she smelled like [ __ ] what a
psycho hey
yeah okay how many poems that's good oh
please please please you're incomparable
like a okay dismount
he I don't say I haven't say you're
incomparable like closed book is one of
the best poems well I have a pen I'm
very glad you have your show is a
wonderful place it's very nice if
something doesn't force and I'm very
proud of you man and you deserve this
and I want to say this in case of
short-lived but I decided shortly so no
I had a short live show sure and but
this is great you should be happy and
excited for while you're here and during
it because this is very very great and
it's not forced at all and we have
conversations together alone we cheat
out to an invisible how do you think ah
I'm very very proud of you and I think
everyone here thank you boo thank God
little boy